i'm big into sucking tits
how long do you suck the tits for as
long as you go yeah
uncomfortable
a girl just lays there like
[Music]
uh then just
make sure we're looking towards the lens
like the past few times we've been like
having side covers oh okay
look at that directly into it even
important talking like just gotcha why
why would that why would that matter all
right
i guess it looks stupid
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna break the entire time i'm
not gonna blink hi i'm shane gillis hi
i'm matt mccusker and we're here to
answer the internet
matt
is there any athlete you would be okay
with [ __ ] your wife serena williams
i've been thinking about this a lot
lately i've been thinking about dk
metcalf
and what that would do to me
like the devas because think about oh
yeah think about all the guys think
about all those poor ole miss alumni
that dk i mean dk metcalf whoa
he's a horse i haven't seen him he
literally would be if you wrote down
this is getting racist
the last guy
the last guy i would kind of want it
i mean every time i watch him play i'm
like
[Applause]
you'll see i'll be white knuckle in the
cap you won't even notice my
he would do what i would like to do
he'd probably lift her the whole time he
would it'd be like it would be like that
it'd be like you know that
porno one yes
where there's two boxes i've heard of it
they both look like they came back
two dk's and a lady just mid air what
percent of showers do you jerk off
i would say 25
what would you rather have a 10-inch
dick with no balls or a 4-inch dick with
balls well
[Laughter]
i think we know
life's pretty good
but obviously a
yeah 10 inch take notes these balls do
me no good well nobody i mean the girls
don't like the balls you don't really
need the balls they're getting away
they're just kind of they're fun this is
nice yeah exactly i guess i would guess
i've been doing this
i would miss this could you get like a
four inch wide boy
yeah like a girthy for like a soda can
well the girls
they hate the balls but some of them
don't like 10 inch dollars oh at least
that's what they truly for sure
[Laughter]
girls are constantly quests for average
pipe dude do you like it
nothing
but it's like they do say that but if
your boyfriend was like perfect had a 10
inch dick you'd be [ __ ] super happy
about that i don't think no way dude
nobody i've ever dated
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] compliment what
i've heard girls say this be like some
they're too big that's not good i like
yours it's like thank you
that's the truth you could put any
franchise restaurant in your house what
would it be sweet green easily healthy
going with the health yeah man 20th in
the year of 20 in the year of omicron
bro
true you just had it it woofed your ass
it got me pretty good no it's not funny
anymore is it still very funny
i tasted his bio weapon dude and i want
nothing to do with it that was
definitely a bio weapon dude i felt it
you can tell when you can buy a weapon
versus natural sickness that was a
bioweapon
that was made that was man-made that's
both of our dancers yeah i would put the
nih i know what i'd do if i didn't i'd
put the i'd put the nih in my house and
keep an eye on them that's what i'd put
in my [ __ ] house
i would get a wet market from wuhan yeah
i would like just wild [ __ ] animals
that's true
just guys munching bats
would you go to a football game at a 70
000 seed stadium if you knew that 500
seats would get ejected into a black
hole but everyone who didn't get ejected
would get five million dollars yeah i
want the black hole
i'm gonna get ejected into the abyss i
know
the real benefit here would be being one
of the guys that gets gets to be ejected
into a black hole a full grown great
white versus a full-grown polar bear in
an olympic-sized swimming pool that is
seven feet deep and 75 degrees
fahrenheit who wins
great white great white easily this
isn't even close gray white
not to be trifled dude a great white's
so much faster
that's not like that does not suit the
great white's
abilities what do they say about bears
they say if it's a if it's a black bear
fight back they asked us they put this
out just so that yeah
you guys just wanted to talk
you guys love bears
well polar bears are hungry that's why
they're like that they never find food
true so that's why they're a little
vicious but
come on dude great white bro
polar bears are losing the [ __ ]
weather
polar bears aren't [ __ ]
[ __ ] shane would you rather have
free strippers for life or free pizza
for life
free strippers is that yeah
let's getting [ __ ] yes i'd rather get a
ton of [ __ ]
that's what girlfriends are girlfriends
are definitely just yeah you'd also need
you would need a lot of coke to keep
free strippers for life satisfied yeah
you could just keep getting free
strippers yeah but what are they gonna
do
you ever hang out with the shrimper
no me either the uh
wait you wouldn't you wouldn't like that
hanging out with strippers no don't hang
out with strippers all the time oh yeah
you're a married family man yeah i don't
mind bringing the ladies in no it turns
me on my wife dude my wife is so [ __ ]
hot dude free strippers [ __ ] gluten
allergies
so i can get like a you know i can get a
cauliflower crust or something just
unlimited cauliflower across that sucks
why are you lying about this answer free
strippers
what am i going to do with them bring
them to your house make them perform
yeah and leave and then pay four bucks
for a pizza
they're gonna they would they would hype
me up
they would stoke my fire they would
stoke my fires and i'd make love to my
wife
we would the card would have said [ __ ]
if we meant horses it's strippers
they're dancing and giving you lap
dances okay so they're not touching your
penis at all they're like rubbing your
dick 83 percent of the readers chose
pizza you got a low tea audience
a lot of dudes hate strippers though
they really do they pretend to hate they
say they do yeah i've seen it guy i've
said it a thousand times and i keep
going to street it's a problem like
that'll be uncomfortable i don't like
going to them
what's your real name i love you i
should go by myself did you ever go to
strip club by yourself
no donna you went to the strip club
alone multiple times how was it it's
pretty cool it chilled i don't like the
loaners
they always like walk up to the thing
you know
it's because it's their girlfriend yeah
it's their girlfriend oh yeah yeah
there's dudes that like bring them lunch
and stuff right yes
that's dark
no dude it's a girlfriend you guys want
to hang out you guys were all free
strippers a second ago this is the
reality of it
would you rather give up sex or the tv
remote for the rest of your life uh the
tv remote yeah i don't care yeah you got
to give them a second i'm pretty remote
hungry guys you're remote hungry you
know i'm remote
you've seen i've given up the control of
the
yeah so i'll television
hang out with my friends with
like-minded ideas
we're watching trump compilations
yeah i'd rather have sex for life dude
sex for life dude
sex is like you got for 15
all you're doing is giving up the remote
you're living like my girlfriend lives
currently
she has no say in what we watch
right she gets through it now you watch
sometimes you get a good thing dude i
just watched pirates of the caribbean
one do you ever see pocs dude that was
good yeah poc it was getting this
weekend and i watched this weekend i
just watched poc sometimes you get to
get one i love ps4 girls do have
obviously the worst taste it's always my
music and then the second they get
i listen to kendrick lamar
be like me which fictional character
would you love to beat the [ __ ] out of
captain barbosa from pirates
[Laughter]
prophet muhammad sean penn and i am sam
i would whoop his ass dude you shouldn't
have a kid you think you're fit to raise
this dumb kid
and i beat his ass in the parking lot
after the hearing
i would do uh sharp monster charlize
theron i saw a lady i'd beat her up for
killing them
that murderer
before she did it they could travel back
in time i'd
she's a [ __ ]
i'd hit her with like i'd hit her with a
crowbar just like all the other johns
you'd get tricked so fast
would you rather a [ __ ] yourself every
time you come or b get a boner every
time you talk to a dude yeah just b get
a boner every time i talk to a doctor
yeah i would chop him up yeah
definitely problem how often do you have
boners
usually early morning flights that's a
boner for like three hours yeah you ever
get an uncontrollable long bonus
long flights early morning drives
yeah get in the car yeah i don't i have
no problem having a boner is no problem
yeah so boner
part of the tuck method i mean that was
all of high school i talked to dudes
while having a boner the entire time
there was no problem
in fact think of all the conversations
you and your boys were both you wrecked
on a lot of them some of my they're my
fondest memories dude my boys hard as
hell chopping it up chopping it up it
was always great when there was a kid
who didn't know the talk method true who
didn't know the talk dorks like when the
teacher would be like come up and
present and they were like i don't want
to
but if it's gym day you got the
sweatpants in a catholic school and then
you might protrude the sweatpants that's
[ __ ] dude it's just now it's a helmet
dude
i've told this i've told you this one
time
it was uh
it was in eighth grade and we were
lifting for football and i had a boner
in the weight room
so i talked
with my gym shorts but then it was my
turn to bench
so i laid down and my shirt came up
the tip of my upside down penis was
sticking out
and my friend who was spotting was like
shane's penis is out
and everyone had a good laugh i died and
then i wrapped 2 25 okay
at all
no i it was over
i mean that was a long time ago
that was
[Laughter]
that dude's reaction so ashay's penis
[Laughter]
if you could [ __ ] anyone you wanted but
they'd die immediately after who would
you pick
doctor
[Laughter]
every white dude at ole miss would be
like yeah
you can play one video game for the rest
of your life which would it be
you don't like gaming though jet moto
too you know what game i played for a
very long time was echo the dolphin
remember that
and i it i never got out of the first
level i played fifa for a very long time
yeah ncaa
ncaa i'm still playing yeah okay
no question exactly right kevin thank
you for knowing me
better than i know myself through gta
gti
if you could party with one sports team
from history who would it be 1997
russian olympic team 1936 german
olympics
[Laughter]
what a wild time that would be if there
was a database of your lifetime internet
history how much money would it take for
you to make it public 500 that would be
my number i would be embarrassing how
much i searched myself yeah that would
be
but like it's not porn it's like it's
other [ __ ] like that although there's
some porn yeah this is definitely
yeah it's definitely not important it's
not poor at all no one's worried about
that oh you're bored fired up i'm an
open book i'm sure you're very public
about it yeah
oh yeah guy's not lying what's the
weirdest porn you watch deep horn bro
that's not weird anymore that's i was
ahead of my time
but now i hate it that's just [ __ ]
jump dude
t
t porn dude yeah
oh yeah yeah we just say the full word
yeah we talk about the community
mathematically it makes more sense for
us
i've heard this i've heard this argument
yeah it's true
with this argument
about the guy has nice tips
too and like a nicer i've tried it dude
you see like the clavicle while they're
[ __ ] i'm just like that stinks
that's regrettable
the first one i love happening because
matt was talking about t porn a lot and
i was like i'll give you a couple names
bro well bailey we all know all right
aubry
dude you can't do a family i watched one
matt told me to watch it i watched one
and there was a part where the
the t was going at it and finally when
the t finished he was like that was just
like
yeah what have i done but when the guy
does that you don't have a problem i
like guys
i like guys you don't want your guys to
just be guys and not have my guys having
fun
i like big guys having fun true
true and you know what i don't like is
the little hump
women
not for me that's scarier than people i
would say
i would agree with you on that
just nubile boys having sex with mature
women disgusting
sound wholesome but when you call them
that it makes them a little more
once you describe them as new you're my
own boys
now you've peaked my interest
talk matthew if you could be a master at
one of the four bases of sex but you'd
have to be below average at every other
base i think what are the bases yeah i
think we're both pretty good at eating
[ __ ] for sure and that's it and we are
below average in every other fish i
would excel at sucking titties dude yeah
just be nasty yeah that's crazy you
mentioned that i've gotten into that
it's the best i'm big into sucking tits
do you suck the tits for so long
yeah
uncomfortable how do you encounter a
girl
[Laughter]
oh yeah
don't worry babe i got you and then i'll
start sucking the other one she's like
my nipples are actually they hurt
you've chased them
do you
do you laugh do you latch
[Laughter]
yeah yeah dude latching's a [ __ ]
well you you just recently had a child
you must be running into some
some nip holes bro yeah i'm patiently
waiting in my return
i don't want to cross wires yeah cause
that's exactly yeah i don't want to show
her what's good i'm gonna have the baby
baby who also has your dna
who would probably be naturally
oh yeah
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon